welcome to armex logic metagenomics
this course is going to introduce you to
bioinformatics analysis of metagenomic
sequencing data
in this first session we will start by
speaking about genomic sequencing
technologies
as one of the methods to study microbes
and
map out how such data can be used then
we will introduce you to several data
analysis tools for metagenomic studies
and take a look at a few examples where
such analysis approaches
have been used let's start by reviewing
a little bit of history of microbiology
where the study of microorganisms led to
the creation of
tools and approaches that are still used
today and continue to uncover the veil
of a world which we do not see but yet
has such a profound effect on everything
around us
for millennia the smallest thing humans
could see was about as wide as a human
hair
when the microscope was invented
suddenly we saw a new world
of living things in our water our food
and
in fact everywhere around us the first
observation
of a bacterium was made around 1673
by the dutch microscopist anton van
thanks to the microscopes he has
developed
those enlarged whatever he studied from
50 to 300 times
as the resolution of the microscope
improved more and more representatives
of the unseen world
have been discovered today the
microscopes
are tremendously powerful allowing
humans to see smaller and smaller
elements
that reveal how the world of
microorganisms functions
and every imaginable surface
microbiology
is defined not only by the organisms it
studies
but also by the actual tools used to
study them
these tools have evolved to allow us to
study microorganisms and categorize them
technology for bacterial culturing
coupled with
a technique to stain bacteria and view
it under the microscope
has improved our ability to isolate
categorize and determine
whether a bacteria is a cause of human
disease
and even select an appropriate treatment
more advanced technologies like
sequencing are now being used
to further study the complex
environments where such bacteria
originate and grow the discovery of
culture media
allowed for the development of
microbiology in the 19th century
bacterial culture is the artificial
medium that allows growth and isolation
of bacteria the first to have cultured a
bacterium in a reproducible way
was lewis pasteur in 1860 today
such methods are still often used and
are being driven
by discovery and perfection of specific
mediums
to grow and cultivate bacteria in the
lab
gram staining is a bacteriological
laboratory technique
used to differentiate bacterial species
into two large groups
gram-positive and gram-negative
based on the physical properties of
their cell walls
gram stains are performed on body fluid
or biopsy when infection is suspected
gram
stains yield results much more quickly
than culturing
and are especially important when
infection would make an important
difference in the patient's treatment
and prognosis examples of gram staining
applications are cerebrospinal fluid
for meningitis and synovial fluid for
septic arthritis the connection between
disease and microorganisms has been
established already in the 1800s
these studies provided important
information about bacterial function
in isolation however it became
apparent that most microorganisms live
in complex communities
many members of which are actually
impossible to culture in isolation
today we know that the microorganisms or
the microbiota
that make up the human microbiome are
not just unicellular organisms living
alongside each other but instead
form highly regulated structurally and
functionally
organized communities attached to
surfaces as
biofilms with inter-species
collaborations
as well as antagonisms that contribute
to ecological stability
due to the advances in metagenomic
sequencing and other armix technologies
today we have enormous databases of
sequence data
from such communities which has led to
the emergence
of computational metagenomics this
discipline allows us to study the 99
of uncultivatable microorganisms
in the context of their natural
environment the stability of such
communities
is fascinating as many of us probably
know from trying to battle such common
skin conditions as
eczema acne and dry skin forming
distinct communities
these microorganisms are interconnected
and determined to maintain
their community bacteria within a
biofilm
can communicate with each other by
producing detecting and responding to
small diffusible signal molecules
in a process called quorum sensing which
confirms benefit
for host colonization biofilm formation
defense against competitors and
adaptation to changes
in the environment quorum sensing
activities and biofilms are also
involved in the virulence and pathogenic
potential of bacteria and are therefore
an important factor in the understanding
and controlling bacterial infections
as they enable microorganisms and
biofilms to become
more tolerant of host defenses and
antimicrobial agents
inside each community there is a balance
of bacteria
fungi and viruses that control species
abundance
and activity the human microbiota
is extremely complex it is estimated to
be
10 to the 13th to 10 to the 14th of
microbial cells
with around one to one microbial cells
to human cells ratio
these numbers are derived from the total
bacterial
cells in the colon the organ that
harbors the densest number of microbes
however each one of these microorganisms
carries
important functional properties in genes
that contain genomic information
these properties and the genomic
information about microorganisms have
been
of growing interest to the scientific
community
resulting in over 80 000 publications
the majority of the studies have focused
on the intestinal microbiome
however since the 1990s microbiome
studies were significantly advanced
through such major initiatives as the
metagenomics of the human
intestinal tract and the subsequent
human microbiome project
these are huge studies that have been
made possible through the advances in
metagenomic sequencing
as a result skin lung gut
and even brain microbiota is starting to
be characterized in great detail
each new project represents vast
opportunities
as well as challenges to determine which
microorganisms play key roles
in the development of certain
environmental conditions
that are needed for healthy function of
human organs
and which can be harmful to it over the
past decade
more than 1.7 billion us dollars has
been spent
on the human microbiome research major
projects are
also underway in the united states the
european union
china canada ireland south korea and
japan
this investment has confirmed the
importance of the microbiome to human
health
and development some 20 percent of us
investment in such research has gone to
two phases
of a huge project called the human
microbiome project or hmp
which is creating the research resources
needed for studying the human microbiome
one of the main objectives of the hmp
launched in 2007
was to create a toolbox of reference
data sets
computational techniques analytical
methods
and clinical protocols many of the
findings from this project
is what we will focus on in this program
it is because of the huge investment of
capital and human research that we know
that the endogenous human microbial
communities contribute to critical
metabolic
physiological and immunological
functions including
differentiation and maturation of the
immune system
food digestion and nutrition energy
generation
metabolic regulation and control of fat
storage
processing and detoxification of
environmental chemicals
and maintenance of skin and the mucosa
barrier function
as well as development and regulation of
the pro-inflammatory
and anti-inflammatory processes and the
prevention of invasion
and growth of disease-promoting
microorganisms
metagenomics is the genomic analysis
of microbial dna from environmental
communities
metagenomics tools enable the population
analysis of unculturable or previously
unknown microbes
the ability to identify microbes without
a priori knowledge of what sample
contains is opening new doors in
disciplines like microbial ecology
virology microbiology environmental
sciences
and biomedical research unlike other
omics
metagenomics does not study a single
organism
but the whole community at once it
provides us with a snapshot
of a collection of organisms directly in
their natural
environment since the genomes are so
diverse
this is typically accomplished by
sequencing a specific
marker portion of the genome instead of
all the genomic material
present in a given sample such marker
gene
has been the 16s ribosomal
rna 16s amplicon sequencing
is a recently developed technique that
is widely used to study
microbiome directly in its environment
this metagenomic sequencing focuses
on the 16s or the 18s gene
within the small subunit of the
ribosomal rna
it has to be amplified with pcr
amplification
and that's why it's called amplicon
sequencing the 16s gene sequences
contain hypervariable regions also known
as
hvrs that provide species specific
signature sequences used for bacterial
identification
the benefit of amplification is tied to
the nature of sequencing read length
which can maximize effective output from
affordable sequencing technologies
to account for the diversity of such
sequences they are usually combined
into operational taxonomic units or otus
which can be used to classify groups of
closely related individual sequences
otu's are formed from groups of closely
related genomic sequences
and represent a cluster or a
phylogenetic clade
that has a meaningful abundance in a
sample
such otu sequences are annotated by
mapping
to a reference database such as the
ribosomal database project or rdp
green genes or the silva database such
databases contain
taxonomic information for the domains of
bacteria
archaea and eukarya based primarily on
phylogenies for small subunit
ribosomal rnas based on the mapping of
specific regions
amplified from the 16s ribosomal rna
gene and the small subunit of the
bacterial ribosome
otus can be assigned to belong to a
taxonomic class of bacteria
yielding a proportionate view of the
community
each community can then be studied by
comparing with other communities
or between individuals and conditions
such analysis requires an in-depth
understanding of data preparation
methods
reference databases as well as
analytical approaches to answer specific
questions based on solid evidence in the
data
importantly sequencing data represents
only one type of microbial omics
with many more becoming increasingly
available
in fact many questions about the role of
microbiome members
in communities are now being answered
using next generation sequencing
as well as mass spectroscopy approaches
for proteomics
and metabolomics indeed it seems like
the next phase of microbiome research
lies in the ability to integrate
multi-omics data sets
that combine next generation sequencing
mass spec
and structural data with detailed
phenotypic information
about overall changes and the results of
changes in the community
and the environment it produces now you
have learned
about the history of microbiology the
emergence of sequencing technologies
and hostage data can be used to study
microbial samples
so let's now discuss additional
resources that you can rely on
in this program to study these topics in
greater detail
these will also include practical
analysis tools for you to get experience
with such data sets in the following
sessions
we will look at example data sets and
run
analysis together but for now let me
give you a brief overview of the tools
methods
and project examples associated with
this program
the materials in this program are
expanded
in our metagenomics core series which
includes
introduction to metagenomics
metagenomics 1
2 and 3. each module in these courses
is designed to provide an explanation on
rationale
and objective provide engaging
activities
additional multimedia resources and
tutorials with examples and practical
applications
importantly the course material will be
reviewed
in module quizzes and tests these are
timed
and tied with overall student progress
the modules
also explain key terminology as well as
explain some of the project data sets
that we will use
in the analysis let's now talk
a little bit about the practical
analysis approaches that we will cover
in this program throughout the course
you will be given directions
to access the t by info platform for
bioinformatics processing
and analysis of metagenomic data the
platform includes demo pipelines as well
as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines on large data
sets
different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections
of this multi-omics platform
the visual interface of the tbi info
platform will enable users to quickly
build
logical graphs of their analysis and
understand
each step's significance and role in
what's called a bioinformatics pipeline
for those interested to implement the
pipeline on their own we will offer
guidance
and references that can be used to
effectively install
all of the needed packages that are
explained
in the program behind many of the
methods
are scripts written in popular coding
languages such as r
and python these are also explained in
tutorials that you will have access to
these are beginner tutorials on data
importing preparation for analysis
and standard visualization of processing
data as well as
more specialized packages with
publication ready outputs
that will also be covered in more
detailed sessions
so what kind of projects can be studied
using metagenomic sequencing and how
will we get data
for these projects there are many
applications of microbial research
that include skin conditions food
sensitivity of the gut
autoimmune disorders cancer antibiotic
resistance
drug resistance and even ecological
studies
in this program we will learn to find
and analyze data from such repositories
as the human microbiome project
which includes a data set called the
american gut
this is a citizen science project that
has a lot to offer
for those interested in basic microbial
composition
of different types of samples from
healthy and mildly sick
or unhealthy individuals but we will
also look
at more controlled studies where animal
models were used to separate the roles
of environments
lifestyle and genetic inheritance to
study microbiome
association with such conditions as
anxiety
following the gut brain axis other
examples we will review
include studies of microbial drug
resistance
viral adaptation and analysis of soil
bacteria but microbiome seems to be
involved in many more important areas of
biomedical research
for example screening for diagnostic
signatures in precision medicine
and association with treatment efficacy
or the therapeutic considerations for
microbiome transplantation study such
conditions
as alzheimer's disease that's why we are
not just going to focus on
the examples that we provide but we will
provide you with a framework
on how to go from data to integration
and analysis
that leads you to ask specific questions
and rely on data
to be able to perform the analysis
independently
after completing this program you should
be able to find
analyze and interpret metagenomic data
on your own
if you have any questions along the way
you can always post a question
on the program forum before the next
session
we ask you to start working through the
metagenomics course series
below this video you will also find
important links
to additional reading material on
metagenomics and associated
bioinformatics methods
you